[Musique]
ross cowley général de vous voir
chaque fois qu'une guerre est gagnée le
plus dur reste à faire maintenir la paix
c'est bien ça depuis cinq ans humains et
pilote cohabitent plus ou moins
pacifiquement
mais plus maintenant
si nous ne trouvons pas une solution
nous aurons trois milliards de morts sur
les bras mais nous avons déchiffré leurs
données de navigation
nous lançons le premier vol habité
direction leur monde vous pouvoir vous
permettre d'interagir avec les
technologie extraterrestre
je tiens à vous avoir à bord
l'heure est venue de leur rendre la
monnaie de leur pièce
c'est tout
donc vous avez une moitié plein ouais au
mieux
mesdames et messieurs je vous présente
cobalt s'il ya le moindre mouvement
brûlé tour
ya du mouvement vers le mur nord de
signature
c'est quoi
on est cerné
est-ce que l'extermination de l'humanité
nous devons absolument repousser nos
limites
suis consciente des enjeux
je suis prête à me sacrifier
le mettre fin à ce bordel une fois
beaucoup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]